les 40 secondes par les bons c'est parti
ok allez go go l'alsace est très beau
comme ça regarde l'asie à toi le plus
mais en tout ce monde est en route voilà
pour ça qu'ils soient accueillis les
points fragiles
je vaux rien comme elle est belle la
rivière l'arrière
derrière la fumée et à l'ombre de la
fumée dans le truc on va même pas à
l'oeil le voit dans la vidéo c'est
sublime sa
venue constitue la rivière où on va
directement sur le sur le feu
de
nouveaux rites avril à la lampe de la
fumée sur la rivière c'est magnifique
et l'effet de la sage un peu c'est un
peu un peu petit le fétiche de suspendre
un peu du fait rouler dessus qu'on peut
te pendre grands pas encore prononcé sur
le feu parce qu'il y est payant quand il
sert et comprennent était au tour là
parce qu'il faut pas un petit peu quoi
de beau c'est beau comme ça c'est super
beau comme sarah labeur sa sauber ce
flanc l'arrière d'un assez bossé bossé
ce night by day mais ça va pas du point
face à rien n'a pas dû faire ça ok oui
oui
ne devrait pas durer si tu auras tu vois
directement dessus vas-y revient
non mais pas lui allez on repart c'était
très bon mais tu joues pas tu comptais
là-dessus ok vous en raison le feu
selon le stationnaire de subir par
n'est plus le avait le feu de la
renvoyer dans leur
ok on va voir le feu sur le dos en
petit feu vraiment les bornes auxerre
dedans tanguy l'on sache passée par là
riahi tout-petits si je suis à l échelle
sont rendus mais la rivière le lez le
feu dans la rivière ça va être très beau
parent je tourne alors le
voilà regard voilà voilà voilà il ya
regard regard hagard l'agar agar les pas
trop serré et toi tu vas tu vois le feu
dans la rivière
bah ouais mais en serrant l'a pas vu mon
poste j'ai tourné alors
ce magnifique soleil fit
danser plaisir on veut pas toujours des
joueurs on se fait de la sambre partout
est non voyant et la santé.la encore va
s'arrêter arrière 2 voilà
bientôt diable sur le feu mais je vais
gagner a pris dans l'air sur lyria
reliant la gare à l'ombre du feu dans la
droite là c'est vachement beau et panet
la race et
tout flou pour moi ainsi que normalement
la corse est bon
il faut tourner à gauche la corrida
chapeau savage eye
bombay cousteau en voyage dans les
étoiles le contrat c'est dur là c'est
vraiment beau c'est super beau c'est un
patin couffin à merde de beauce on n'a
rien à perdre a dit on va faire la même
chose dans ce sens sera ok
on a fait la même chose auquel il n'ya
dans nature une valeur sûre le sur le
sol peu importe voilà un jeu en vue du
démerde toi la rivière nouveau tube
phare air lines allez on va sortir comme
ça si on sort comme ça et on sort par la
hockey et on sort de sion passer du
feuillu ensemble
le descente super g soit en vie non non
moi je laisserais comme ça c'est large
et je partirai comme ça voilà ok oui
comme quoi tout ce cap là ok
bon c'est bon pour s'amuser pour dire on
fait des trucs
voilà on envoie au camp et on sort du
chan voilà merci pour le flash sur le
plan devant
lui
et quoi le flash
l'avait voulu prendre
bon ok
c'est bon pour vous les enfants
magnifiques il faut que votre corps peut
rejoindre la sous location
celui-là outre
ok ça donne ça vous pensez que c'est
possible ça oui c'est possible parce
qu'il ya peu de brillance c'est
vachement bosses ses
posters et même plus appréciés
super beaux
arts plastiques
hp met à fond
on a assez sublime sa
foi peut faire métro jeudi à flat à leur
sortie mais ça me permet d'avoir une
valeur dans les eaux au caire se faire
un peu un peu fait de rendre aux fans ce
n'est pas la regarder mais reste lucide
et havrais dégradé